you
hi everyone is cheering this is the game
between Anatoly Karpov playing on the
white end against Viktor Korchnoi this
was from their 1974 candidates final
match a round 2 game and really a model
game for this opening one that does well
to highlight its many thematic ideas so
let's dive in here and see what happened
out of this Sicilian Dragon and to be a
bit more exact we have the Yugoslav
attacks securing that Bishop pairing a
battery we have a case of opposite sides
castling in this one white already
prepared to peel open the H file and
there we go queenside castle Knights C
form and the first moment to really
touch on this is where what moment is
this well the first moment where black
has established peace in White's house
and it should not be overlooked the
lateral influence the rook has I say
this because what is commonplace for
white is to welcome a dark square Bishop
exchanged with Bishop to h6 this dragon
bishop
should not be seen as worth only three
he is both master defender and attacker
and it makes a lot of sense to seek this
type of exchange eliminate one of the
key defenders of blacks King and well
you can't play Bishop h6 yet because of
Knight to e4 and we can observe this
convergence now on D form so what does
white do plays H five pitches upon in
order to open up the H file so white has
some avenue to attack white still can't
go in for this same tactic as present so
what is played is Knight d2 e2 there are
many things to note
and with this last move what is it doing
well first off it is preparing to
finally play Bishop to h6 there's no
longer this pressure on D form and what
else well it's important to realize one
of the ideas of black has on the Queen
side and that is some type of exchange
sacrifice on c3 in order to damage the
white King's home it won't it won't
always be the case that both Queen and
Knight are around to recapture on c3 so
the knight from e2 is securing the c3
point and also with this last move we
can observe that the major pieces can
now see the world a little bit more
clearly along the D file and so with
this there comes also the idea to play
e5 and then g5 just to highlight if a6
is played like and play e5 and after
capture boom that's the last defender
that's the second of two defenders on d6
and white will soon pick up the bishop
so
the game follows with Queen to a5 Bishop
h6
ship takes bishop queen takes bishop
there is also an idea to simply back up
the bishop this is important to know you
know it does well this move this move
here emphasizes the value of that dragon
bishop black can play bishop to h8 and
say you know what I'm cool with giving
up the exchange as long as I have master
defender and attacker around you know
you're not going to get at my King so
easily
was not played but it is an idea Bishop
takes Bishop Queen takes Bishop in the
game
only now does black double on the C file
and now the game move rook to d3
if white tries some type of brute-force
approach to this position namely playing
the move g5 this is not good this is a
really good defender I was pointing out
the dark square bishop being a really
good defender but so too is the knight
on f6 he's holding things together it's
just by a thread but that's enough if he
tried to shoo the night away with g5
note that black does not have to be
there to defend h7 directly there is
this indirect approach where you can
simply interfere with the Queen and
rooks coordination on h7
now this follow-up idea of Knight to f4
is just the timing is not there the idea
is to you know finally crash through
eliminate the knight and then boom mate
but black is there black would be their
one move sooner smashing through on c6
Queen takes c3 and that's as far as I'm
going you'll just have to trust me that
this is a minus 14 evaluation and
climbing fast
okay black is there in time how are you
defending all these main threats okay
you're not
in the game we had rook to d3
is defending this idea of an exchange
sacrifice on c3 it should not be
overlooked that black couldn't even go
forward with some type of double
exchange sacrifice on c3 if ripped to d3
wasn't played something like this is not
crazy okay
this night is basically negating the
Queen and rooks influence on the H file
and it's black who's now generating
threats against the white king
something to know double exchange sac on
c3 so what does Karpov play rip to d3
rook to c5 recon for to c5 is aimed at
preventing g5 a better move is to have
the Queen run home and seek a queen
exchange in the game it was rook to c5
again aimed at preventing g5 so that you
can secure the night but Karpov plays g5
in any way he says go ahead take take
the pawn if Knight to h5 Knight to f4
carp Korchnoi picks up the phone and
this is a nice position to throw a quick
pop quiz at you what move would you play
here as white we're looking to continue
the attack how do you continue the
attack here from this position go ahead
pause the video what move would you play
is white
okay the star move here is rook to d5
not Knight to d5 and maybe the
temptation now let's go here and we you
know kill the knight next and then crash
thrown h7 but Knight to d5 is met with
rook takes Knight and after pawn takes
Bishop f5 black is the one on the attack
this key King side defender is still
around so what do you play rook to d5 or
what a beautiful interference move and
this is ultimately prepared to eliminate
the key the piece that's the super glue
for the Kings Kings position the knight
on f6 wrote to d5 star move rook takes
rook only now Knight takes d5 or the
knight Hopson to d5
following up we have ripped ee8 this is
this is one for teamwipe too many
threats here capturing on e7 capturing
on f6 the game move rook to e8 and white
just needs to invite one last piece into
the attack it's important not to take on
f6 too soon this may be very tempting
but yeah this King would be weaseling
away if you go in for something like
this it's not so easy how to get at that
King further it's a different story if
this naked maybe jump on into d5 not the
case here so one more prep move before
this final flurry of exchanges before
eliminating the night we invite that
last piece into the attack Knight f4 and
now white is ready to take the knight
and then go in for that variation in the
knight would be ready to go into d5 so
the game follows with Bishop to c6
five this is a beautiful move this is
interfering with the Queen's sight of g5
once more taking on f6 and then looking
for this little tactical idea of night
to h5 you know looking at this mate
threat on g7 and in the event the night
is captured I made on g7 in this way
well that can be met with Queen to g5
and uh Queen's are now off and we would
have this type of position that is in
the computer's eyes dead equal Bishop
and two ponds for black and a rook for
Team white
'if I've interferes with this Queen to
g5 idea in other words Bishop takes
Knight pawn takes Knight mate threat on
g7
he takes F and what to do from here is
now the time to play Knight to h5 since
there isn't Queen to g5 no because it
would be white who ends up getting mated
keep in mind this is the first moment
easy to overlook easy to get caught up
in this attack attack attack mentality
you know this is the first moment where
the majors are converging on e1 so what
do you do instead of Knight to e5
now you crash through with Queen to h7
King to f8 Queen to H a and it is at
this point that Korchnoi resigns he sees
what's coming what is that exactly well
how the game would follow is after
Knight Eric's human King de 7 there
would be Knight takes Bishop check
and after the Queen takes the night now
we go to e1 and pick up the rook next so
a very nice game out of this Sicilian
dragon again I think it's one that does
really really well to highlight many of
its thematic ideas so feel free to leave
any comments to this one and I will
catch you in the next video that's all
for now take care
you